So Donald Trump held another one of these
press briefings yesterday, and the press briefings
are increasingly sort of an outlet for Donald
Trump's panic over failed interview after
a failed interview on Monday night.
The Axios interview that Trump gave to Jonathan
Swan was such a train wreck that Trump decided
yesterday morning.
I'm going to call in to Fox and Friends.
That'll be a nice softball interview while
we reviewed the Fox and Friends interview.
And again, Donald Trump was a complete and
total disaster.
He seems unable to help himself.
So yesterday in the afternoon evening, Randt
running half an hour late, put him sort of
in the evening as a category.
Here on the East Coast, Trump had another
one of these White House press briefings and
it was just unfounded conspiracy after conspiracy.
Donald Trump losing all connection with reality.
And I want to take a look at some of the key
moments now.
You might remember that on Tuesday, Trump
had floated the idea that the explosion in
Beirut, Lebanon, was an attack.
And he also mentioned that it looked like
a bomb.
Now, at the time, there was no evidence of
that whatsoever.
It was completely irresponsible for Donald
Trump to float that idea.
And since as we learn more about what went
on, there continues to be a complete lack
of evidence that that is what happened.
Donald Trump was asked about it yesterday
and multiple town times doubled down, floating
even more conspiratorial ideas about explosive
devices, all with zero evidence.
Also, one other thing here that I want you
to pay special attention to.
You're going to notice that Trump starts referring
to Lebanon as that country.
He never says the word Lebanon during this
entire press briefing.
It looks to me that Donald Trump doesn't know
that Beirut is in Lebanon.
And so he avoids having to make that clear
by referring to Lebanon as that country pay
special attention to that.
The primary focus of this clip is Trump's
baseless conspiracies.
So there's been some question about your comments
yesterday saying that it was an attack and
that you heard from military officials that
there was an explosion that took place.
That was.
I can tell you whatever happened, it's terrible.
But they don't really know what it is.
Nobody knows yet at this moment.
They're looking it could have been how can
you say excellent?
Somebody was, you know, left some terrible
explosive type devices and things around.
Perhaps perhaps it was that perhaps it was
an attack.
I don't think anybody can say right now we're
looking into it very strongly right now.
It's.
I mean, you have some people think it was
an attack and you have some people that think
it wasn't.
In any event, it was a terrible event.
And a lot of people were killed and a tremendous
number of people were badly wounded, injured.
And we're standing with with that country.
You know, we have a very good relationship
with that country, but it's a country under
a lot of turmoil, a lot of problems.
But we stand with them.
None of what Donald Trump said there is based
on any fact.
He says maybe someone left explosive devices.
There's no evidence of that.
He's just making that up.
Some people think it was an attack.
There could have been explosive devices.
There's no connection to reality whatsoever.
Now, you expect this stuff from, you know,
the enclaves of the Internet that we've all
come to, sadly, be familiar with over the
last three and a half years.
But this is the president of the United States
just randomly and wildly floating conspiracies
that occur to him.
Then another one here, Donald Trump posits
without any evidence that there was some kind
of conspiracy in New York congressional primaries,
all to make him look bad.
This is just wild and unhinged New York.
They had the Carolyn Maloney situation, and
I criticize it badly over the last two years
and two days.
I mean, I gave it some very, very strong criticism.
And all of a sudden, like a miracle, they
just approved the winner.
Well, what happened?
Did the person that was second concede the
race, even though was very close and all mixed
up?
They have a terrible situation in New York
with the ballot.
You know that.
And as soon as I said, well, I think you should
have a new election because the election,
obviously, they're not going to know what
to do.
I think you should have a new election.
They all of a sudden announced a winner.
I assume it was her, but they announced a
winner.
Well, I don't agree with it.
Did somebody speak to the person on the other
side?
The opponent, did they do something for the
opponent on the other side?
Take a look at Patterson, New Jersey.
Take a look at many things.
It's all over newspapers.
What's going on with the mail in ballots?
They vote.
They send out millions of ballots.
Millions of ballots are totally unprepared
to do it.
And then they come back in the millions.
It's going to be a disaster.
Completely baseless allegations.
And remember, Donald Trump keeps talking about
vote by mail fraud as a reason not to vote.
By mail in November.
And he points to this New York race.
This situation in New York is related to postmarks
and mishandling by the city.
There has been no voter fraud alleged in this
race at all.
Never mind confirmed.
None of that race has anything to do with
fraud.
And yet Donald Trump is fully in with these
baseless conspiracies.
Now, then at the end of the press briefing,
again, the topic of Beirut was brought up
and Trump sort of stumbles through the answer
and abruptly ends the press briefing again,
failing to ever say the word Lebanon.
It seems to me Trump doesn't know that Beirut
is in Lebanon.
And again, saying it could have been a bomb
that was set off despite there being no evidence
posited so far for.
Based on what hear?
The incident any day, she felt it was an accident.
He's disagreed with you on other things before
you have any comment about whatever he.
If he if that's what he heard.
I think that I've heard it both ways, too.
I've heard accent.
I've heard, you know, explosives.
And obviously, it must have been some form
of explosives.
But whether it was a bomb intentionally set
off, it ended up being a bomb.
But now I've heard it both ways.
It could have been an accident and it could
have also been something that was very offensive
and I wouldn't be very happy with it.
No problem.
You just have suspicion that the explosion
is a bomb.
Do you have any plans pertaining to U.S. assets
in the region, for example?
I mean, how how are you looking into that?
We're working very closely with the government
and we're working very closely with many different
agencies, including the military, and we'll
be able to figure it out.
We already probably have figured it out.
Thank you very much, everybody.
What is abruptly walking off, of course, after
floating multiple, multiple unfounded conspiracy
theories?
Now, just a bonus clip here.
Not a conspiracy per persay, but just the
wild claim.
Donald Trump again talks about, you know,
coronaviruses just going to go away.
This morning on rotavirus, this thing is going
away.
Like things go away despite going places.
It's not going away.
No, it'll go away.
Things go away.
Absolutely.
It's not in my mind.
It will go fretfully sooner rather than later.
Now, what's pernicious about this is that
to the non-thinking individual, eventually
Trump's going to be right and he's going to
get some credit for that.
And what I mean by that is I guess it's conceivable
that the coronavirus goes away as a pandemic,
but it becomes sort of seasonal like the flu.
But in a certain sense, eventually Trump will
be right that the pandemic is going to end.
Now, Trump has been saying this for months.
When we had 15 cases, the president said they
would soon be zero.
We're now at five million.
He's been saying it's going to go away for
five months.
At a certain point, he will be right.
And there are people in our country so uneducated
or so blinded by partizanship that they are
going to praise Trump for it.
They will say, look, Trump said it was going
to go away and it went away.
It is weaponized ignorance and aggressive
delusion.
And it's dangerous.
And I.
What do you guys think these briefings are
helping Trump with some people that do these
briefings, help Trump with his base?
Or are they doing more harm than good?
You'll remember they were stopped for a period
of time and then restarted as an idea for
helping Donald Trump recover in the polls.
He actually has seen slightly better polling
since he has restarted these, although to
make a causal relationship, we'd have to have
a little more information.
What do you think?
Helping.
Hurting Trump.
No impact helping with his base, but hurting
with everybody else.
Curious what
you think.